it has been an interesting few days for
the pursuit of artificial general
intelligence so I wanted to give you
some of the highlights from GPT 4
something to recursively improving
semiconductor manufacturing we got at
least five revealing quotes from Jensen
hang Sam Alman and others and the
summary is this if you thought or know
someone who thinks that artificial
intelligence peaked with chat PT you or
they are going to have to weather
exponential increases in computational
power through at least the rest of this
decade as samman just said of 2024 and I
agree this is the most interesting year
in human history except for all future
years so let's start with Sam opman who
said that open ai's goal is to avoid
shocking updates our goal is not to have
shock updates to the world but that's
what we're trying to do that's like our
state of strategy and I think we're
somehow missing the mark
so maybe we should think about you know
releasing gp5 in a different way or
something like that yeah 4.71 4.7 to and
what does he mean by releasing
iteratively without shock updates well
probably something similar to another
co-founder of open aai Greg Brockman he
said that their plan for safety involved
deploying GPT 5 in stages essentially
creating a Continuum of incrementally
better AIS such as by deploying
subsequent checkpoints of a given
training run think of that like saves on
the way to completing a video game in
short it's highly likely now that we
will be getting something equivalent to
GPT 4.5 before we get GPT 5 as to
whether the marketing department comes
up with a better name than GPT 4.5 well
let's see and on timing he said This
Blink twice if it's this
year I
also we will release an amazing model
this year
I don't know what we'll call it we'll
release over in the coming months many
different things I think they'll be very
cool uh I think before we talk about
like a gp5 like model called that or
called or not called that or a little
bit worse or a little bit better than
what what you'd expect from a gbt 5 and
then we have a lot of other important
things to release and don't forget that
not all progress depends on new models
we can have new systems like let's
verify or qar based on existing models
San practically confirm Med the
existence of qar in this interview with
Lex fredman from yesterday can you speak
to what qar is we are not ready to talk
about that see but an answer like that
means there's something to talk about
it's very mysterious Sam I mean we work
on all kinds of research
yeah I've done an entire video Gathering
the best evidence as to what qar is so
do check that one out but if you want
the massively condensed tldr it's this
models can essentially think or compute
for longer on harder questions and
generate thousands of example answers
and have internal systems for checking
which answer is best and only showing
you that best answer a system two to
complement the base system one thinking
if you will but before we leave that
interview there were two more
fascinating quotes at least from my
perspective that I want to show you one
involved the possible social response to
ever improving Ai and the chances of it
going theatrically wrong I worry about
that for AI mhm I think some things are
going to go theatrically wrong with
AI I don't know what the percent chance
is that I eventually get shot but it's
not
zero I'll come back to social responses
later in this video but that was a
startling moment at the moment at least
thankfully the power struggle for AGI is
only financial here is Demis aabis
essentially laughing when an interviewer
said that open AI was a nonprofit lot of
AI Labs have grappling with governance
and what is the best structure for
something like AGI to emerge you just
mentioned the possibility of some sort
of international Collective or
cooperative that would handle this but
um you know across the industry like
open AI has set itself up as a nonprofit
with a for-profit subsidiary anthropic
is a public benefit Corporation so
before we get to nvidia's GTC let's
linger for a moment on AGI its
definition and recent updates to the
timeline to AGI yesterday Andre karpathy
who was until recently at the very top
of open AI said this about the
definition of AGI he thinks of it like
the open AI Charter as being an
autonomous system that surpasses humans
in most economically valuable tasks and
is it me or does that definition not
automatically foreshadow economic Strife
in other words definitionally AGI won't
have arrived until it can do the work of
at least half of all humans now every
word matters when we're defining
something as conse quential as AGI and
Google deepmind led by demes arbis
moderated open ai's definition they said
we'll count it as having achieved AGI if
we have systems that are technically
capable of Performing economically
important tasks but don't necessarily
realize that economic value as in they
might not actually be deployed in the
workforce for legal ethical or social
reasons but imagine the economic
incentives in that scenario AGI would be
here and be capable of realizing
trillions of dollars of economic value
and these companies are supposed to hold
back from deploying it would Google
allow that would Microsoft or would the
definition change conveniently but even
under that wider definition when does
Demis aabis think that AGI will arrive I
will say that when we start to deep mine
back in 2010 you know we thought of it
as a 20-year project and and actually I
think we're on track which is kind of
amazing for 20 year projects because
usually they're always 20 years away
right so that's the joke about you know
whatever it is quantum AI you know take
your pick and um but I think we you know
I think we're on track so I wouldn't be
surprised if we had uh AGI like systems
within the next decade others think that
that moment which again would have
colossal economic ramifications will
come before 2030 here's one alignment
researcher at open aai he thinks that
there's around a 2/3 chance of AGI
before 2028 and he goes on that he can't
talk about all the reasons why he has
this timeline but mostly it should be
figureoutable from public available
information I'm guessing that's an
oblique reference to qar or let's verify
he also returns to the economic
definition of AGI when I say AGI I mean
something which is basically a drop-in
substitute for a human remote worker
Circa 2023 and not just a mediocre one a
good one EG and open AI research
engineer notice though he's focusing on
remote work and even Kathy limits his
comments to digital work but as we'll
see at the end of this video even
physical tasks might be automated sooner
than you think before we leave Daniel
KOCO tagilo though there's one more
quote I want to show you of his I think
in this one he's feeling somewhat
panicked probably there will be AGI soon
literally any year now and probably
whoever controls AGI will also be able
to use it to get to artificial super
intelligence shortly thereafter he says
maybe in another year give or take a
year now if you do the maths of that
comment give or take a year means that
it could be instantaneous or it could
take to years from AGI according to him
at least according to google Deep Mind
an artificial super intelligence would
involve outperforming 100% of humans
just like in their respective domains
Alpha zero and stockfish already do and
in the light of these shortening
timelines some AI researchers are
already adapting their behavior one lead
researcher at open aai said this the
closer we get to the singularity that's
the moment when progress is so fast
humans can't even keep up the lower he
said my risk tolerance gets I'd already
ruled out skydiving and paragliding last
year I started wearing a helmet
consistently while cycling and he ended
I think this year might be the year I
give up skiing in other words if you
think AGI ASI and the singularity are
going to happen in the 2020s it would be
kind of a Pity to die before that date
probably but at this point in the video
and I promise you I will get to the GTC
straight after this things are getting
kind of heavy so I want to bring in a
paper I read that's on a lighter note
what the paper says essentially is that
peer reviewers are now starting to use
chaty BT wholesale to do peer review how
did they discover this well mentions of
the word commendable Innovative
meticulous intricate notable and
versatile now I think those are words
that I use all the time but maybe not
everyone does previously they were
incredibly rare in peer reviews but they
became somewhat common hm makes you
wonder they go on that the estimated
fraction of large language model
generated text is higher in reviews
which report confidence that kind of
makes sense right if you're not
confident you're going to use an llm to
help you but the next bit is funny they
were submitted close to the deadline so
you have these panicked peer reviewers
who are like oh no the deadline's coming
let's use chbt to do it and the other
correlation was it was more common from
reviewers who are less likely to respond
to author rebuttal now that seems
somewhat unfair to me you don't even
bother to write the peer review
yourselfself and you don't even reply
when the author replies to you these
were peer reviews of prominent deep
learning conferences and the rates were
10 and almost 177% and we're not talking
about spell checks we're talking about
being substantially Modified by Chachi
BT obviously now's not the time to go
through this paper but I thought it's
worth showing you I mean it's one more
effect of AGI right the whole peer
review system might become the AGI
review system so the conference from
around 24 hours ago obviously way too
much to get to in this video but I'm
going to give you the five moments that
stood out for me first the obvious one
the announcement of the Blackwell GPU
over the course of the last 8 years
we've increased computation by 1,000
times 8 years 1,000 times remember back
in the good old days of Moore's Law 10x
every 5 years 100 times every 10 years
one 100 times every 10 years at the in
the middle in the hey days of the PC
Revolution now this graph does involve
some hype because it's not comparing the
same level of precision fb16 to fp4 but
the point still stands that we are
exceeding Mo's law here's another
example the Blackwell Superchip system
isn't just two times better at inference
or actually generating tokens it's 30
times more performance than the h100
series in short there's going to be a
lot more Generations from generative AI
the cost and energy consumption also
drops by a major factor and of course
almost every CEO in the world that you
can think of lined up to praise and
getting the queue for these Blackwell
super chairs next of course the model
sizes that these systems can serve just
keeps getting bigger remember gpt3 was
trained at 175 billion parameters then
GPT 4 at around 1.8 trillion that's 10
times bigger well notice how as we
proceed we're not doubling or 3x in
we're talking about another 10-fold
increase Nvidia said that their server
clusters could deploy a 27 trillion
parameter model now of course just
because Nvidia can deploy that size of
model doesn't mean that the AGI Labs
will create one that big I think a more
reasonable estimate for the next
generation of models would be around 10
trillion parameters but the point still
stands we're not doubling each time in
case you're not familiar by the way the
number of parameters is like the number
of dials in a model that you can tune to
better match deep intricate patterns and
patterns within patterns of course those
patterns have to be found within the
data that you give it so garbage in
garbage out but of course everyone's
working on getting higher quality data
the next interesting moment I think many
people might have slept on Nvidia have
built a platform that accelerates the
compute intensive part of lithography
that's the key process in making new and
more advanced chips and in this
announcement Nvidia say that tsmc are
already going into production with this
platform they're going to be
accelerating manufacturing and pushing
the limits of physics for the next
generation of advanced semiconductor
chips not only that but these 40 or 60x
improvements also utilize gen as best I
can tell they're using generative AI to
create a mask which is key in
lithography think of that mask as a
template that transfers a pattern onto
the chip I'm reading the book chip Wars
at the moment and lithography is
absolutely key to the latest chips but
the bigger point is this they're using
gen for ideation suggestions but then
the actual mask is derived by
traditional physically rigorous methods
it's that marrying of gen to suggest and
traditional systems to check that we'll
see again in a moment but there is
another obvious Point here this is
somewhat recursive we have better chips
creating better cheaper faster
generative Ai and now more and more
we're getting generative AI helping in
the creation of new and better chips and
of course those new Chips might be with
us sooner photo M that took 2 weeks can
now be processed overnight here's what
the CEO of asml said which of course is
the company that's integral to the
creation of semiconductors this
collaboration will bring tremendous
benefit to computational lithography and
therefore to semiconductor scaling if
you thought things were already
progressing fast it'll get even faster
for the rest of this decade one quick
point to make here is that we're
actually still lagging the front edge of
what's computable by about 2 years most
people if they're not still using the
original chat G PT are using GPT 4 which
finished training 2 years ago or Gemini
1 Ultra but I spotted recently from
aabis that gem 1 Ultra actually used
just the same compute as was rumored for
GPT 4 that's 2022 compute levels
actually gini 1 used roughly the same
amount of Compu maybe slightly more than
than what was rumored for gp4 I don't
know exactly what was was used so I
think it was in the same ballpark in
other words the public hasn't begun to
grasp what even 2023 levels of compute
could do for training a language model
but there was of course one more
announcement that I simply cannot ignore
project
Groot this is Nvidia Project
Groot
a general purpose Foundation model for
humanoid robot
learning the group model takes
multimodal instructions and past
interactions as input and produces the
next action for the robot to
[Music]
execute we developed Isaac lab a robot
learning application to train grot on
Omniverse Isaac Sim we can train Groot
in physically based simulation and
transfer zero shot to the real world
world the Groot model will enable a
robot to learn from a handful of human
demonstrations so it can help with
everyday
tasks and emulate human movement just by
observing
us this is made possible with nvidia's
technologies that can understand humans
from videos train models and simulation
and ultimately deploy them directly to
physical robots as Jensen hang said
humanoid robots will at first just watch
us and learn from imitation data but
embodied learning does have one
advantage over large language models
they can use reinforcement learning in
simulation try task in simulation see
how they work out and then perform in
the real world I actually discussed this
with two leading figures at Nvidia for
AI Insiders on patreon but let me leave
you with this thought if you think these
robot imitations look kind of cute and
rubbish at the moment think about gpt2
or maybe the first system of Bard that
you interacted with and now think of GPT
4 or Claude 3 in those cases they were
learning to imitate human text in this
case it will be human actions but the
lesson is the same these models can
improve much faster than you might think
and don't forget with all of this as yet
another open AI employee put it hope you
enjoyed some time to relax it'll have
been the slowest 12 months of AI
progress for quite some time to come
hopefully you'll join me as I cover that
progress in the coming months thank you
as always for watching to to the end and
have a wonderful day